good morning ladies and gentlemen how do
we know when the irrational exuberance
has unduly escalated asset values which
which then becomes subject to unexpected
and prolonged contractions that was an
excellent question when Alan Greenspan
asked it at AEI in 1996 and it is an
excellent and highly relevant question
for us today I'm Alex Pollock of the R
Street Institute and it's my great
pleasure to welcome you to our
conference the bubble economy is this
time different and thank you all for
coming
Peter Wallison the distinguished AEI
senior fellow is going to introduce our
keynote speaker
Peter thanks a lot Alex wonderful to see
such a great crowd here this is an
important day for all of us we're gonna
hear from Alan in a way that we don't
often have an opportunity to to listen
you know it's really difficult to
introduce someone who needs no
introduction but there's so much to Alan
Greenspan beyond his resume and his
celebrity that I wanted to do more than
tell you what you already know one of my
most vivid memories of Alan is when he
was a speaker at a meeting of the
Council on Foreign Relations many years
ago at that point he was the Fed chair I
went because I was trying as a lawyer to
get a better perspective on
macroeconomics the others there were
primarily economists and their questions
were very specific they sounded to me
something like this what about Johnson's
idea and his sessions such article that
the Collingwood's coefficient nullifies
the Ramon D rule it was a complete
puzzle to what they were talking about
but no matter how arcane Adams Allen
seemed to know every detail and
explained where he thought the article
might be right or wrong and on and on
went there did not seem to be any idea
of significance or insignificance in the
economic literature that Alan had not
read and fully recalled it was a bit
discouraging for someone who only wanted
to get a basic grasp of macroeconomics
we first met at the AEI World Forum in
early 2000s when I was writing about the
dangers of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac he
would ask thoughtful questions but never
suggested that he agreed or disagreed
with my views I was happy to see however
that he was becoming increasingly
skeptical about the GSEs in his
congressional testimony then when the
financial crisis occurred he remembered
our discussions and invited me to many
one-on-one lunches at his consulting
firm so he could get a better grasp on
why in my view at least the crisis had
happened in these discussions I realized
that Alan was more exceptional way more
exceptional even than what he seemed
that evening at the Council on Foreign
Relations many economists I read today
seemed to be in thrall to mathematical
models of the economy and the financial
system their papers are full of
equations suffused with incomprehensible
Greek letters and dedicated to
regressing an issue to the point of
irrelevance Alan is not that kind of
economist for most of his career he was
a business economist sat on boards and
absorbed how capital investment among
other decisions were made he could
probably regress regress with the best
of them but what he learned went into a
picture of the vast US and world economy
that was constantly that he was
constantly building and rebuilding in
his head a kind of creative destruction
was going on as new experiences informed
and modified old ones I was certainly
not the only person Alan was talking
with as he continued to plumb the
mysteries of why the financial crisis
was so unexpected and so severe
his circle is wide knowledgeable and
challenging many of you may be here
today perhaps the idea occurred to him
that if the markets were entirely
rational there would never be a bubble
too many rational people would be
betting against them so there must be a
major element of irrationality operating
here finally in 2013 he committed his
ruminations to paper his book that year
the map and the territory was an
exploration of the way human nature
makes economic forecasting difficult the
book tries to meld the rational world of
competition and regulation with the
emotional world of irrational exuberance
and animal spirits it's an effort to
formulate a conceptual structure for
economic forecasting this morning we'll
probably hear where this intellectual
for a has taken him in the last five
years we should have more economists who
think about these truly important issues
at that level one Alan Greenspan is not
enough but at least we have him for one
morning so let's have a warm welcome for
my friend who needs no introduction
[Applause]
first thing I wanna do is to move up one
lodgings I feel around behind me on the
edge of the universe but thanks very
much that's a very thoughtful analysis I
would like to just sit here and get more
of it but you know the interesting issue
is is this time different well the
answer is no it never is if you're
dealing fundamentally with human nature
one of the most important things that an
econometrician can get to see and learn
from is that the resurgence stabilities
in the way economies function because of
the way people function and that is
deeply embedded into the human
psychology which is invariant through
time and shows up with a lot of
stabilities in it for example the rates
of return on investment equity
investment fairly stable going back and
I think the most startling statistic is
the fact that interest rates in fifth
century ancient Greece are not all that
different from today which is
essentially saying that the issue of
time preference on the part of human
beings has obviously not altered once
you can make the statement like that and
verify it in other words as a statistic
which will always be a determiner rather
than acting passively once you can make
that statement there's an awful lot of
economics which unfolds and what I'll
try to do today is to stay away from
this at best I came from
all sorts of equations but I can't fully
because unfortunately you begin to look
at the complexity of human irrationality
it is very complex and to a large extent
irrational so why don't I why don't I
just first move over
[Music]
let me start off by saying an answer to
an answer to the question that's the
basic purpose well you know I make I
make it a state of amnesia that's
important I know who I have the the the
question which is raised for this
seminar is basically is this time
different and the answer is no and the
reason is that the issues were talking
about today are as deep seeded in human
nature as any of the other aspects of
stability that we see through time price
bubbles reflect the deeply irrational
part of human nature while bubbles have
been widespread throughout history their
most fertile source of data to get an
idea of what we know about it is
actually stock prices the reasons I
think the program that evident to all of
you you know we know that if investors
behaved wholly rationally we'd expect
that the information available to
investors yesterday what t-minus one of
you want to do that sort of stuff
would be wholly reflected in yesterday
stock prices and would not spill over
into today
ensure price change yesterday would have
no effect on future prices daily price
change would be a random variable and
therefore would follow on so-called
normal distribution that's the normal
distribution well what we have done is
take a compilation of nearly 17-thousand
daily price changes stripped of their
seven-and-a-half percent annual rate of
growth since 1957 the result has really
few surprises in the short term stock
price behavior suggests a significant
degree of human inertia was less
movement than a wholly random price
change would suggest what I have done is
I've taken the actual 17,000
observations and that is a distribution
which is spikes up I superimposed on it
normalizing for standard deviation and
average and what you get is that sort of
distribution which suggests that human
nature as reflected in the spiked term
is not a random event it is not
developed in the way we would get to
most such statistics and the question is
well why well the answer is essentially
that each observation is related to the
next observation and you can see that
for example most particularly in the
extent to which in the underlying
the actual 70,000 theta in the middle
that's bulging out and when you look at
in detail what's causing that it's
hurting heard the herding instinct of
human beings to follow others follow a
leader and what you'd expect to happen
under those conditions is a price
pattern which everyone is really
contributing to but it doesn't change in
the sense that the fundamentals of
herding deep seeded in human nature and
as a consequence you'll get this sort of
different doubles really quite different
effect mainly because human nature's
human nature cannot be changed has not
been changed as much as we try in any
event more interesting than either way I
would say the indications of just
settlement inertia on the part of human
beings in moving small numbers which get
bigger as if they would get down into
the increasing herding and the life but
the small measures that were saying
they're invariant and show everywhere
but it is not as interesting and don't
tell us as important an issue as what
happens when you take the individual
annual failures and try to get a moving
average of what the variance or standard
deviation is and this is the next
the next chart as you can see there is a
very distinct upward a very distinct of
upward path which it's really showing up
most everywhere
it's the odds in fact it's the most
interesting part of the data that
emerges from its changes through time
starting in the early 1970s a five-year
average of trend seems to have emerged
after years of stay stable long-term
price change when I showed my results
several years ago to Peter Brown our
good friend now chief executive officer
of Renaissance Technologies caught one
of the world's most successful hedge
funds applied complex algorithms to
rapid short-term trading
he replied to note I sent him and I
thought his answer is really quite
revealing it tells it tells us how
somebody who is a quant operator how
they think to those as you know what
they basically do is endeavor to let the
market issue the market movements and
gender investment and that's some of the
complex algorithms are fascinating
especially since they create trading
faster than human beings can respond he
says there is no question that the world
is speeding up in the sense that more is
happening per unit of clock time than in
the past certainly people are trading
faster
and in the past but also the world is
becoming more complex and more is taking
place permitted than in the past and
it's being disseminated through the
economic media more rapidly this would
all explain why daily variants which is
a function of clock time not event time
is increasing since mores happening in a
day than in the past the daily variants
of prices that reflect changes in the
world should be greater than in the past
this is the type of thing which makes
economics interesting you you're always
getting new concepts we're now changing
appropriately so the nature of time I
mean last time it happened
Einstein did it but I just Peter Brown
now taking the podium away from him I
conclude from this exercise of taking
the data back all the way to 1947 that
variance prior to 1972 was stable so the
short period back there 47 to 72 the
variance I think as it shows on the
chart but in recent years there is a
disturbing up trend has emerged stock
market trading and prices of gradually
being driven from less than fully
rational human beings to robots such
results of mixed implications less human
nature is being applied to judge stock
market behavior but it is presumably a
future with fewer bubbles
that's the type of conclusion that is
very important if it is true this is a
hypothesis based on relatively few
observations but it's credible if were
thinking about robots taking over the
world well this is one area in which
they do it
bubble finance has in fact been an
integral aspect of economic forecasting
reaching back to the emergence of the
business cycle during the 18th century
self-sufficient farms dominated even the
most advanced economies economic
activity was decidedly agrarian and
hence climate driven and regional with
the emergence of the Industrial
Revolution in the early 19th century and
the creation of banking and credit
America began to prosper but with it
came a new economic phenomenon the
nationwide business cycle fluctuations
in business activity were increasingly
seen to follow a systematic pattern
characterized by a gradual but extended
buildup of credit and economic activity
followed by a dramatic collapse soon
engendering crisis or panic the terms of
interesting if you go back and look just
a deal normal history history the
panic is applied to virtually all of the
major changes in economic activity
basically from the civil war forward but
it's also sent actually pretty
widespread panic it's an interesting
term because it is a wholly
psychological one and what is happening
is that people are by definition
behaving irrationally and what if we
took a look at the history from today
the first first business cycle
identified which is generally accepted
the BV period
succeeding from 1819 which is I guess
the first financial crisis followed by a
general collapse of the American economy
persisting through 1821 nearly a second
while I put on my reading glasses it
changes my perspective and as a
consequence I can't wait to hear what
I'm gonna have to say
the panic in the survey 18:19 the cycle
the panic announced the transition of
the nation from its colonial commercial
status with Europe towards an
independent economy increasingly
characterized by financial and
industrial imperatives making it
susceptible to boom and bust cycles in
August 1818 with credit dangerously
overextended the second bank of the
United States branch officers began to
inject all state charter reject all
state chartered bank notes exceptions
were made for notes used as revenue
payments with US Treasury in October
1818 the US Treasury demanded a transfer
of two million dollars a species from
the Bank of the United States to redeem
bonds issued to fund the Louisiana
Purchase state banks in the west and the
south unable to provide the required
species began to call their loans on the
heavily mortgaged lands that had
financed the had been financed cash poor
farmers and speculators found their land
values dropping 50 percent or more
banks began foreclosing on the
properties and transferring them to
their creditor the second bank of the
United States when news arrived in
January 1819 that the value of cotton
had broke dropping 25 percent in a
single day the ensuing panic drove the
country into recession similar crises
followed in 1837 1857 1873 1884 1893
1896 and 1907 they all had very similar
characteristics and indeed essentially
represented what you could see in each
of these so-called panics this is a
interesting chart on the operating rates
going back to 1855 we don't have data
before then but what you can see here is
a very gradual uptrend very hard to
discern but what we're seeing is as a
first approximation that the economy's
back to then ran off the ball standard
had species as the base from which their
credit expanded and since species was
essentially limited we have a very
stable environment of data but what the
data show is what happens when you put
human nature in the same bucket as gold
and what you find is fascinating is that
in every single case these particular
periods have been called a panic and the
essential reason is that they start to
develop from Salem the low point and
cumulate up and the standard way we roll
learned over the years that it feeds on
itself the herding instinct to building
that runs straight up until it
accelerates and then in this context to
context to the gold standard it would
hit a ceiling and crash and it's
fascinating to see through the
literature that in every single case
they call this thing of panic and you
could reproduce effectively the
economics of one crisis and put it in
another and it explains it so it's
something which is deeply embedded in
the data but as you can well imagine the
politics became increasingly fiercer and
that as you know the agrarian movement
and basically remember that in this
period agriculture is still a very
substantial part of the total GDP and as
a consequence of that you have a
situation where individuals are
basically looking at the difficulty
getting money for the credits they need
and what's causing the problem well it's
the golf standard or its anything which
restrains credit expansion and the
lobster that did do precisely that and
will have when you see in the data there
is a gradual upswing
the extent to which you run into crises
and you run into crises basically
because species is no longer available
in the vet that's been committed for
other lending and other credits so that
you get the pressures coming from the
Grainger movement and from a whole
series of individuals climaxing I might
add and the extraordinary speech of
William William Jennings Bryan in the
1896 Democratic convention the cross
so-called cross of gold speech which was
fascinating in the sense that what he
Brian was endeavoring to foster was
going to the silver standard and or
other means by which credit can be
expanded but the fascinating part is we
get into the last of these types of
constraints and the crisis of 1907
that's the one in which famously JP
Morgan got a bunch of New York City
bankers into his library on East 35th
Street in New York and locked the door
until they agreed to an agreement to
essentially bail out or give assistance
to the individual members who put in all
sorts of pressures to get help in some
form another and the question is what
happens in this type of environment if
you've got a one awful lot of momentum
going up and it hits a stone wall well
the whole thing comes apart but
supposing you don't suppose he let the
credit run
and that's essentially what happens in
the next phase of the United States
economy in the sense that after huge
amounts of political pressures over the
years and essentially anty anty golf
standard are joined with the remember
the Comstock Lode and silver was
discovered about this time and all of a
sudden had a number of states who were
in favor of silver so that the pressures
in the political pressures were
extraordinary and ultimately they led to
the auger is real in the act tortures
have not passed in 1908 as a consequence
of the 1907 experience you know what
people came away with that and that for
that year is that the single individual
essentially held up the United States I
mean he nothing hold up but he basically
by I getting that gold borrowed from
abroad was able to put the system back
temporarily into place and it seemed
like in a very thin read to have your
economy based on so that all of us real
and created
a monetary conference committee
examining how for example central banks
operated Europe and elsewhere and what
types of things could occur to replicate
that in the United States and lo and
behold up comes the Federal Reserve the
Federal Reserve starts and the bill was
signed in December Woodrow Wilson signed
the building it was December the third
twenty third nineteen well we did spend
it basically I guess they can say the
actual signature was 1913 but the
implementation did not occur at all
until well into nineteen fourteen so you
have a Federal Reserve in 1914 in
endeavouring to counter the problem of
the automatic crushing that occurs and
then this batiste particular periods and
which it what I see you know what you
see there is what happens when you lift
the lid which is essentially what
occurred and we had I don't want to get
into tumors you deep weeds but we
essentially had the sovereign credit of
the United States substitute for species
and if you look at the balance sheet of
the Federal Reserve that's what you're
getting and as a consequence of that you
have a open-ended issue of the momentum
which got stopped in the earlier periods
and broke
the back of the expansion sooner rather
than later
and so that the actual bubble-bursting
did not have the effect that started to
have during the period of the Fed we
have two votes here long term for the
Federal Reserve that's not enough in any
event the point I think that we have to
become aware of is something happened
during this period 1914 turned out to be
obviously a seminal year throughout the
world because of World War one and the
consequences but as far as finance is
concerned the Federal Reserve would
actually didn't technically abandon the
gold standard that had nothing to do
with the Act and in fact that the Act
required that Federal Reserve banks that
twelve Federal Reserve banks hold 40%
backing on Federal Reserve notes and 33
and 35 percent backing in gold on
deposits held at the central banks well
that didn't work very well because as
time went on every time we got close to
the limit 40% and then the whole series
of lesser numbers the goal posts were
moved back and if you go and look it
kept changing the 40% ultimately ended
up with 25% and Lyndon Johnson in 1968
by executive order abolished all of
there wasn't a whimper in the market
nobody shared but it says in effect that
the the Federal Reserve Act which was
supposed to be essentially a major
improvement and as a first stage
couldn't be made to work because the
human human nature of political
pressures when they put it this way were
really overwhelming which what's my
deadline let me get my mouth and it
keeps working
the economic climate since 1914 has
really been a period periods moving from
sound money that is gold dominance to
periods of five paper money supposedly
in critically worthless currency the
reason I say supposedly is remember that
George Washington's General George
Washington
financed the revolutionary war with
so-called cut metals were issuance of
the Continental Congress you all
remember that he were not worth a
cosmetic but they fundamentally financed
the Civil War how well if the discount
rate on the cuff levels started at zero
and then worked its way down slowly so
that a number of years the custom
essentially down to the point where a
cop metal was not because metal but
remember that if you just looked at the
amount of transactions that take place
as the just discount rate on the
currency goes down they in fact did
create a substantial amount of
purchasing power that fed the under that
fed the continent the US revolutionary
cause middle troops and much else and
this issue of so-called fired currency
having no value shows up in all sorts of
things I might just add parenthetically
today that's what the bit that's what
Bitcoin
it is a intrinsically a worthless
currency but it's accepted because
there's an expectation that other people
will accept it and this is what happened
with the greenbacks of the Civil War and
the life and the whole period of
Americans monetary history throughout
the Civil War period into the Gilded Age
or all issues were there's a fight
between five currency and gold and some
form another and which finally in 1971
as you know Nixon closed the gold window
before we ran out of gold and gold
ceased to be an issue we had floating to
the US dollars which hasn't worked all
that badly and it's for the same reason
that fight money generally is acceptable
and when you put the sovereign credit me
whatever that means but in the United
States it's essentially means that you
required legally to accept currency see
redeemable currency but the whole
history of Finance is admixture of the
irrationality aspect of human nature and
believe me as you're looking at fired
currency and you can find value in it
something's got to be wrong but it is
but as I say you you know you see it
everywhere and if you never I mean what
people start to do after Bitcoin took
hold has had their own cryptic
cryptocurrency and it kept some of its
Jeff being accepted
for exactly the same reason that the
cost metal was accepted and I'd like to
don't only get too far into Bitcoin but
I think it's tells you a great deal
about how fun it's fundamentally works
in any event that puts us into the most
recent series as you know we have had
really some success in having a
basically fired currency but it's
essentially not fixed remember it was
largely controlled in some courts in the
past with you know when we got out of
the Bretton Woods Agreement and
basically the number there was 1944 we
essentially set the dollar on a major
new course which we were the major
currency until which everyone wanted a
piece of and that ended in 1971 but the
point here is that the system still
works we will remember that when you
have a floating exchange rate there is a
certain degree of restraint that occurs
because if you endeavor to expand it too
fast the exchange rate goes down and
this is the reason why it's sort of an
interesting half of will halfway
compromise and finance but fundamentally
it all comes down to human nature
bubbles and I've done an answer to the
question
is this time different I would say yeah
every time it's different but it remains
the same what why don't I open up for
questions thank you very much tore
through ideas history bubbles we're
going to have a brief question time may
remind you of of our rules wait for the
microphone to get to you when it does
tell us your name and your affiliation
and then ask your question if you
suddenly find yourself overcome by the
urge to give a lecture instead of asking
a question the chair will remind you to
come to your question so they see I
think I have a question right here and
then we'll come here then I'll come over
to you let's let's start here please
thank you very much Larry checkout check
our communications mr. Greenspan if I
may I think what you're talking about
when you talk about species is trust and
I would ask you how much trust should we
place in our financial institutions and
our American dollar these days depends
on human nature
obviously this Trust is a critical
aspect to finance you couldn't have any
complex society where there's people are
willing to trust somebody over a
protracted period now we sell 30-year
Treasury bonds people are willing to
hold it
well why because they believe that even
though getting back to five currency
they will get their currency back and so
that you take trust out of a financial
system and it collapses because it's all
based on interpersonal reactions and the
reason that JP Morgan was able to get
those people in in 1907 in that room and
beat on them is that he had emerged as
the extraordinary person whom everybody
for whose word everybody trusted and he
you know remember when we were running
out of gold he basically got foreign
central bankers to bring gold back into
the United States just when we're at the
point of defaulting now that is trust
and the question is old where did it
come from well it came from a long
period of Morgan would say he'd never
looked at anybody's balance sheet he
just
I don't believe this I did say you
looked at the person and can tell
whether he was trustworthy but the point
here is that if you had a whole listing
of what human nature sort of the forces
of human nature trust is one bubbles or
another these are all invariant yes we
could say when everybody trusts
everybody that's part of the herding
which takes us to the bubble thank you
had a second question wait wait for the
kool-aid for the microphone please view
is the historical precedent excuse me
and you tell us who you are
Julie gbn is the historical precedent
for where the markets are today and
other markets are vulnerable now for
sudden withdrawal of the liquidity by
dark pools and why after significant
correction the overvalued stocks keep
going up now again the question is I
think the question of where are we now
if we look at this historical pattern
can't do are we now in the grips of a
new hurting overvaluation we're not
saying we're always partly in that grip
just a matter of degree if you're asking
me
our equities overvalued well I think you
have to ask yourself basically in the
world would we do is we take instead of
looking at price earnings ratios we look
at earnings price ratios and we can just
construct that as the sum of real
long-term interest rates inflation
expectations and by far the largest and
volatile part has equity premiums and
right now
equity premiums I've just somewhere in
the range of normality for real issue
his real long-term interest rates are
exceptionally low indeed if you look at
the history of the United States and
before they took this very short-term
move recently they have never been I
mean going back to 1789 now if as I
indicated before interest rates are
stable as it's a human characteristic
there's only one direction in which that
can go and what I think he couldn't say
is I argued that they were supposed to
stopped about bubbles and interest rates
before the bond market bubble should
stay and at the time and the bond market
bubble is essentially the determining
force because to reach equilibrium it's
gotta move
whereas all other aspects have a lot of
fluctuation it is at its low interest
for real interest rates are at the
lowest levels of extremis extremity and
by definition if you're at your lowest
levels only one direction you can go but
if that goes up then it changed it
ten tends to alter the earnings price
ratio and would bring stock prices down
and that's what's happening I'm not
gonna go out there and be a stock market
forecaster
but I know what the forces are and it's
a question here of trying to determine
which is the driving force remember that
the the stock market is being driven to
a large extent by the one thing that I
think the Trump administration did right
cut the 35% corporate tactical corporate
tax rate and brought it down to 21
percent I think that probably caused
those wealth of everyone watching
Ireland Ireland did exactly the same
thing in 1998 and it had been pretty
dull economy before that and immediately
thereafter it was you know five years or
more that's a productivity increase was
more than 5% for a year now it's an
extraordinary change and I think that
what is happening here in the United
States is were under estimating the
impact of that was remember going back
to my preset period when I used to be on
a lot of boards I would sit there and
watch them go through the evaluation of
a particular project to get board
approval and at the very end of the
cycle was this is our pre-tax forecast
this is our after-tax forecast and all
you have to do is move the
tax rate several percentage points and a
whole whole check cascades of projects
go fall on the let's do it
type of relationship and I think that's
what's happening at the moment the only
difficulty is that the stock market
cannot go up irrespective of the cash
flow in every us like that if real
long-term interest rates are of the
rising so it's a trade-off here between
which of the bubbles is going to be
determined and I have a capacity not
tough to answer that question I think
I'm that point unfortunately we are out
of time but thank you very much now
would you hopefully stay in your seats
for just a minute so the beginning of
dr. Greenspan a chance to have a clear
exit here and then we're going to call
the panel up in just in one minute
you
standing panel to follow dr. Greenspan
Marx and to continue this discussion of
human nature bubbles and and their
unfortunate aftermath well how do we
know when asset prices are in the grips
of irrational exuberance and have become
inflated to bubble status and if we knew
what should we do about it
and where are we now and how culpable or
perhaps praiseworthy are the Fed and the
other major central banks for inflating
asset prices and what are going to be
the lessons of this cycle let me
introduce the panelists who will give us
the answers of course pointing out that
the answers are not required to be
mutually consistent among the among
depend first we'll hear from Bill white
who is the chairman of the economic and
development review committee of the OECD
in Paris he's an expert on monetary and
financial stability as well as the
processes of international cooperation
in these areas it was head of the
monetary and economic department of the
Bank for International Settlements and
spent 22 years of the Bank of Canada
rising to deputy governor in 1988 he
began his professional career with the
Bank of England in 1969 which as we were
saying was the same year I started in
banking as a trainee so he and I have
lived through all the same financial
crises together
next will be Vince Reinhart the chief
economist and investment strategist for
Standish Mellon or he is responsible for
developing views on the global economy
and making relative value
recommendations previously Vince was
chief US economist at Morgan Stanley and
a resident scholar at AEI where he and I
often discussed financial cycles bubbles
crashes and their aftermath but we
didn't stop them from happening
Vince was with the Federal Reserve for
24 years most recently as director of
the division of Monetary Affairs and
secretary and economist of the Federal
Open Market Committee next will be Adam
Posen the president
the Peterson Institute for International
Economics Adam has written extensively
about the financial and economic
challenges of the European Union Japan's
economic crisis to monetary and fiscal
policies of the g7 countries Beebe is an
external voting member of the Bank of
England's rate setting monetary policy
committee where he advocated an activist
policy response to the most recent
financial crisis and serves as an
advisor to the US Congressional Budget
Office our last speaker will be Desmond
Lachlan a resident fellow at AEI where
he focuses on the global macroeconomic
onna me yeah and is known to many of us
and perhaps many of you for his
constantly sunny optimistic outlook this
includes his recent comment in a letter
to the Financial Times that the new
Federal Reserve Chairman Paul has quote
the unenviable task of having to defuse
a global financial market bubble unquote
Desmond writes extensively on
international economics financial crises
debt bubbles currencies strains in the
euro area and such daunting financial
problems as Greece Italy and Puerto Rico
and as you know is the organizer of this
conference for this timely discussion
each panelist is going to speak for from
12 to 15 minutes after that we'll give
them a brief chance to react to each
other or clarify points then we will
open the floor to your questions and
we'll adjourn promptly at 12:30 bill
many thanks for being with us
are we getting you the clicker for your
slides we ladies and gentlemen of AEI we
need the clicker for the slides I have
no slides I'm psyched just a minute
we've got it we've got it coming here
okay thank you bill thanks again for
being here and you have the floor and
you have the clicker there we go in
particular for the invitation to come
here many happy memories in those days I
was a young man and I particularly
enjoyed talking to an older man who was
herb Stein and herb of course was the
guy who invented the phrase if it's
unsustainable it'll stop and that I
guess is going to be a bit of a
sub-theme so from the sound of it
we're a start off with a little
pessimism finished with some pessimism
and hopefully get some more optimism in
the middle I've only got four slides one
for the past well two for the past one
for the present one for the future and
the reason why I've got more slides
about the past is that I remember it
better than the other bits I'm not gonna
take as with his word a broad and
historical scope as chairman Greenspan
but I do want to talk about the last the
last 30 years you know the line I've
only got a minute so let's talk about
the world so in four slides let me let
me get on with it how did we get into
this mess leading up to the crisis of
2007 I I want to suggest that as
chairman Greenspan said we've had sort
of irrationality and bubbles and panics
and you know from time immemorial I'm
also very aware that Vince here has
actually written a lot of stuff about it
there's now a huge literature about all
of these historical episodes I think
this most recent one
it began with good news they all begin
with good news and basically in a Fiat
money system it's very easy for rational
exuse
prince2 morph into irrational exuberance
and it and it happens all the time and I
want to suggest that in the last 30
years the real driving force behind what
we've seen the good news was the
demographics so we had a combination of
the baby boomers coming through China
Slovakia all these command-and-control
economies coming back massive increase
in in supply if you want to put it that
way now the natural sort of thing that
goes along with a big supply-side shot
like that is very rapid real growth and
a very strong tendency for
disinflationary pressures so you get a
big increase in supply the demand
doesn't keep up and what you see
essentially is what you get well a
monetary policy I guess what I would
contend is didn't really lean against
the credit expansion that was going on
driven by this good news none of the
sort of public policies resisted this
upswing in the kind of way that they
should have done and you you can see it
actually we had cycles for example there
was some reference to it earlier on we
had a we had a big setback of credit
driven property thing set back in 1990
we had another one in 1996 in Southeast
Asia in 1998 2000 and finally of course
2007 and in each one of those cases what
you saw was that monetary and fiscal
policies never leaned against the upturn
as much as they leaned against the
downturn and so the upshot is cycle
after cycle after cycle we had a
ratcheting down of interest rates and a
ratcheting up of debt and so the
problems that we faced as of 2007 were
in a sense cumulative because of the
sort of same policies being followed
year after year and while this was
mostly a phenomenon in the advanced
market economies it spread to that to
the emerging market
economies as well and the basic
rationale was pretty simple which was
from the perspective the emerging market
economies if you guys in the industrial
countries can print the money without
limit and the credit without limit in
order to get your currencies to go down
which is what was going on in the lead
up to 2007 we China and everybody else
can print the money without limit to
prevent our currencies from going up and
that's basically what happened and so in
the end it was as I saw it an accident
waiting to happen that certainly was the
message we were trying to get across at
the BIS but it's very difficult to get
people to see a bubble when they're
inside a bubble what's happened since
well when you think back to about 2008
2009 every policy you can think of to
lean against the downturn of 2008 to
2009 was was brought out of the closet
okay so we had very very easy monetary
policy we had discretionary fiscal
expansion regulatory forbearance cars
for clunkers short time working remember
all of those things but very quickly
what happened was that the government
realized that the long-term effects of
all of these things were not desirable
and gradually all of the stuff was
reversed and the most important one I
think was the early reversal of fiscal
stimulus because the Germans managed to
convince everybody that Greece was
everybody's future and we all had to
pull back personally I think it was a
big mistake we can talk about it later
but in the event all of these other
policies turned around and became
tighter and regulatory policies in
particular were part of it so that
instead of the regulator's focusing on
have we cleaned up the last crisis they
went almost immediately into crisis
prevention mode to prevent the next
crisis that - I think was was a big
mistake but what it did was it left
monetary policy is the only game in town
and of course as you're all well aware
we've done an enormous number of
reinvent of things with monetary policy
since 2008 I won't run through them all
but the bottom line is that they're
essentially more of the same because
those policies are all premise tone the
idea that aggregate demand will be
stimulated by these easy monetary
policies and secondly you can forget
about the unintended consequences
because they're not big enough to worry
about the fundamental premise and the
first point that I want to make here the
second last bullet is that it has in
fact failed to raise these easy monetary
policies they fail to raise aggregate
demand in the way that people
anticipated so we've had it's been
almost 10 years ok and many countries
are still not back up to the pre-crisis
level of of output we had 9 years in a
row where the IMF the OECD the Fed and
virtually everybody else was forecasting
it's gonna get a lot better next year
and then it never did so they had to
revise the forecast back down again it
hasn't worked as intended and I would
point out as Keynes himself predicted we
often hear people say that these
policies are actually Keynesian policies
because they stimulate demand they're
not
it's Keynes of that Keynes of the
treatise in 1931 advocated the policies
that people are following today by 1936
when he wrote the general theory
wonderful line in Chapter 12 or 13 I
think if we are tempted to assert that
money is the lid is the dream that
stimulates the system we had best
remember there are many slips twixt the
cup and the lip and then he goes on to
prove why it won't work well so much for
assumption 1 it will work assumption -
no no no no side effects no imbalances
I'm going to suggest here that the
imbalances are huge they're diverse it's
not just the asset prices it's not
equity it's a whole range of things
first one I want to point out is that
global debt ratios are now 40 percentage
points of GDP bigger than they were
2007 so if you think this crisis has
been a period of deleveraging think
again it's been the very opposite and
one of the problems is that whereas
previously this problem of debt was a
problem of the advanced market economies
now it is truly global China Southeast
Asia Latin America and one of the big
problems is corporate debt been a huge
expansion in corporate bond issues by
people who are none resident of the
United States there's something like 10
trillion dollars worth out there now
without taking into account derivatives
and all that other stuff just overt
exposure ten trillion dollars in in in
in currencies issued by in dollars by
none residents of the United States
asset prices at unsustainable levels
we've talked a lot in the last week or
so about equity chairman Greenspan
talking about the bond bubble
we know that cough light loans now are
record highs
the vixx's of being a record lows up
until just last week the just enormous
number of places my own country Canada
debt ratios household debt ratios
household prices at levels never seen
before same thing in all the Nordics any
country that managed to keep the banking
system going has pumped out mortgages
since 2007 we've got some real issues
there I think the risks of financial
instability have risen as a result of
easy money the first point of course is
that the margins have been squeezed for
the insurance companies the pension
funds everybody's in trouble even the
banks are now complaining about it
belatedly they've been taking on all
sorts of risks that they wouldn't
otherwise have taken on before that
trend to instability I think is being
compounded by structural developments
the insurance companies and pension
funds have the demographic problem to
deal with
the banks have got the problem of high
tech to deal with and on top of that
comes this threat really from ultra easy
monetary policy and I think you can even
go so far as to suggest that it may
contributed to the slowdown and
productivity growth so we think we think
what we've been doing is increasing
aggregate demand and of course it hasn't
worked you can make a very good case
that at the same time it's actually been
doing something on the supply side
that's not very healthy so we think
about these zombie companies there was a
big meeting I was just out in Paris a
week or two ago there's zombies that are
everywhere companies that the banks are
afraid to put out of their misery so
they stay there and compete against the
guys and garages that would otherwise be
able to get a loan from a bank even
though they had no collateral so all
sorts of things out there that I think
are unfortunate about what we've done
well where to from here and this is my
last slide I said right at the beginning
that I thought the basis of the good
news that kept the rates low that kept
the boom going was the demographics the
baby boom going through the arrival of
China it's all going into rivers it's
all going into reverse we know that the
baby boomers are out of here the labor
force is already falling in China and
Japan so this is all going to go into
reverse and I think what that means is
that the inflationary pressures will be
stronger and that really ought to mean
that monetary policy moves into
tightening mode and I would add here
about the rising imbalances that all of
those things and the last slide that I
didn't like one reason why you ought to
tighten monetary policy is to stop them
from getting worse but the difficulty is
this and it's the second bullet that's
what my colleagues at the BIS referred
to as the debt trap which is the debt
levels are so high you have to tighten
policy to stop it from getting worse but
if you do tighten policy you may
actually trigger the problems that
you're trying to avoid and so everybody
started temporizing and you can see it
in the way the feds been behaving over
the course of the last year or a couple
of years where they're not sort of
moving ahead in the way that I guess we
might have thought that recent shocks
like the tax change would have implied
that they should do so we're in a were
in a place where we don't want to be and
I would just note by my judgment and
region in the world has got serious
economic and political problems so that
everywhere your luck is subject to some
kind of a possible shock and I guess my
point would be that in the kind of world
in which we live where you've got all of
these interrelationships the trade the
value-added change the financial
everybody's got the same Bloomberg and
Reuters okay a shock anywhere is a shock
everywhere so I think the whole thing is
is is is we're in a difficult situation
one that I think it is possible to
imagine we could get through but frankly
I think the odds are stacked against it
well what are we gonna do my second last
bullet hoping I'm hoping this time is
different but preparing for the worst
and what I mean by that is that if you
think their problems not even
necessarily or likely but possibly
coming down the road
prudent policymakers should be preparing
for that time and my contention would be
that we are well short of having done
the stuff that we need to do I think for
example about memoranda of understanding
between the various actors in a crisis
are they adequate I don't think so
Deposit Insurance the Europeans in
particular still got a big problem in
terms of euro Deposit Insurance lender
of last resort I know how Scott was
speaking here just a few months ago I've
talked about the way in which dodd-frank
basically is gonna tie the hands of a
Fed I talked earlier on about the ten
trillion dollars worth of dollar
denominated liabilities that are out
there when the crunch comes there's a
lot of people gonna be short of dollars
who's gonna give it to him the Fed maybe
this Congress gonna let them maybe
there's a lot of uncertainty it's a
million miles from an international
financial monetary system okay it's a
kind of international none system and I
find it all very worrisome what should
we do when the next crisis hits I'll be
honest with you I don't know I finished
with this I can tell you what will
happen
what will happen is what happened in
2008 which is that the monetary spigots
will go on the fiscal deficit will blow
out there will be regulatory forbearance
etc etc because that's what has to be
done and it will happen again
the only thing that I do hope is that
one recognizes next time that relying
and continuing to rely on policies that
are unsustainable it's not appropriate
because if someone from this institution
one famously said if something is
unsustainable it will stop
thank you Bill I'm tempted to call a
five minute break so everybody can call
their brokers instead we're going to
well to go on to this the opportunity to
be a relative optimist is quite striking
and I to have a presentation first of
all I think we should commend des for
scheduling something so far in advance
the week after there was about a four
trillion dollar change in u.s. mass
market capitalization in about 24 hours
that's pretty striking thank you for the
invitation I would admit however I would
come would have come anyway since it is
in my latest post-nuptial agreement to
intervene for any non-sanctioned use of
the phrase this time is different
yeah shame shame on you I also like to
thank you for putting me in the familiar
position of explaining what Alan
Greenspan just said that's easy because
I think when it comes to asset prices in
monetary policy I know know of no one
who's been more influential in my own
thinking and I too like Alec will start
Alex we'll start with the ER text the
most famous rhetorical question of the
second half of the twentieth century but
my focus isn't on the famous two words
in that it's rather the framing because
what great chairman Greenspan did was
summarized the hard part
of asset pricing and monetary policy how
do we know when asset prices are wrong
and work building from that I'm going to
take a four part trip first gonna talk
about the presumption required for an
understand to make the assertion that
asset prices are wrong
I will indulge a little pedantic
exercise because Finance offers a very
useful distinction between miss pricings
and asset bubbles and knowing that
distinction is helpful in talking about
policy which will be my third topic and
then lastly before you get too impatient
I will talk about pricing or the most
evident miss pricing in global economy
right now
so first the presumption basic message
is that pricing long-lived assets is
complicated and it is difficult to be
confident about the appropriate level
this starts from the generic asset
pricing formulation that chairman
Greenspan talked about the price of any
long-lived asset is its income stream
discounted by some rate of discount and
that income stream could come from
dividends coupons rents royalties and
the discount rate is the sum of the
risk-free rate a risk premium less any
expected capital gains because you could
get some returns from the capital
appreciation in turn the risk premium is
an amalgam of attitude and perception of
risk pretty straightforward but it also
lends itself to confident extremes
because there are so many different
moving parts you might assert for
instance that all those components are
pretty well approximated by historical
averages in which case you're on the
left here asserting markets are just
almost never right you're only at fair
value in passing but you can also look
at that same formulation with all those
moving parts and say they can justify
anything markets are never wrong
if they can move around to explain
valuation so that four trillion dollar
change in market capitalization was a
revision towards attitudes toward risk
in about twenty three hours
I think policymakers actually sit in the
uncomfortable middle in which assets are
mostly viewed as approximately valued at
fundamental but fundamentals unless
there is considerable evidence of
outsized expectations of income or
capital gains an unusually and
temporarily low risk-free rate or
unacceptable accept unsustainable
acceptance of risk also note in this
formulation when some assets are
overvalued other assets are relatively
undervalued like I personally think our
conversation about house prices would be
much better informed in the u.s. if
rather than asking why do households
devote so many resources to homes by
asking why don't they own more
businesses why don't they have more
resources in retirement accounts
sometimes looking on the other side of
the coin is helpful now my little
excursion and this is more than anything
about the title of this session finance
makes a useful distinction and that is
all asset price bubbles are over
valuations but not all over valuations
or asset price bubbles an over valuation
occurs when net demand is unsustainable
prices are high but not in a way that
will be sustained prices can be wrong
they can be wrong for a long time and
they may be long wrong longer than your
investors have patience a bubble occurs
when expectations of outsized capital
games feed up rising valuation people
expect capital gains that increases
their demand for an asset that increases
the price of that asset that creates
even more expectations of capital gains
and the feeds on itself that is prices
can be
increasingly wrong I think that's a
useful distinction because an
overvaluation does not require ever
rising prices they could persist and the
variety of policies could be in play
including the central bank setting the
short-term rate and suppression of
volatility the government's
encouragement or discouragement of
specific assets again housing is a good
example we say in the US that that the
American dream is to own your own home I
think that's wrong the American dream is
to get rich quick if the government
channels household finance to favor
housing don't be surprised that there's
a lot of resources devoted to housing
and sometimes in that narrow channel if
overflows wears to well and then lastly
it could be something about foreign at
appetite for your own domestic assets on
the right side a bubble as chairman
Greenspan said is intrinsically wrapped
up in human nature deflating a bubble
requires to find the general public
sentiment indeed you have to testify
before Congress and say people who have
thus far been proven right are getting
too rich once popped also a bullet a
bubble like a balloon is hard to
reinflates is probably why crises are so
costly now I like to think of an asset
price bubble as a runaway trolley and
that's going to be helpful for two
reasons as we turn to a discussion of
asset prices and monetary policy admit
it let's face it it it's an unconvincing
prices have always been an important
part of setting of monetary policy but
the bubble component can be especially
hard to deal with that is the expected
mean and variance of asset prices matter
for the setting of monetary policy at
the Fed we used to talk about in the 90s
and the early 2000s the asset price
syllogism
you can see the fingerprints of Alan
Greenspan on this because of the lags
and the effects of monetary policy
actions must be based on the economic
outlook to achieve the mandated goals
the prices of some important assets
matter for that outlook and therefore
asset prices influenced the setting the
monetary policy now there's a Stein
supplement for the two the syllogism
associated with Governor Jeremy Stein
which basically takes account of
variants policymakers must take account
of the risks to the achievement of their
goals a significant asset price
correction may be a tail risk the
railing the achievement of their goals
at a considerable cost therefore
policymakers should react to significant
miss pricings that raise the probability
of a crisis means and variances of asset
prices do matter now we're gonna take a
ride on the trolley I admit a very
anachronistic phrase first we have a
case study of someone who stretched out
on the tracks to try to stop the trow
trolley and that was Alan Greenspan 20
years ago approximately he defied public
opinion by in that quote talking about
irrational exuberance I would point out
at as at the right subsequent to that
speech the Dow Jones Industrial Average
closed below the level just before the
speech a total of eight trading days for
the remainder of his term in office that
is point three percent of the experience
of the remainder of the Greenspan fed
there's another reason to talk about
trolleys and that's the theory because
the trolley problem has an interesting
background in ethics and it's also a
favorite of undergraduate coffee houses
so imagine a trolley is careening out of
control and that you are at this
which you have your choice you can Lily
leave the switch untouched and that may
lead to the probable death of 12 people
in the trolley you could throw the
switch
send the trolley on a different track
and that male it probably almost
certainly lead to the death of two
people which is better passively accept
the possibility of harm to some or
actively cause harm to others and there
and the fact is there's no right answer
in that the decision depends on the
value weights and your understanding of
the potential victims the subject
subjective interpretation of phrases
like probable and almost certain your
willingness to take blame based on your
action and all this is assessed in real
time with limited information oh maybe I
was talking about monetary policy
because a mispricing could lead to a
policy action or not letting the
mispricing persist may raise the product
passively raise the probability of
financial crisis but do you want to be
actively in front of that and and
therefore allow your account potentially
to have below trend growth but perhaps
Jeremy Stein would say stable even below
trends growth there's no right answer
and that's why asset prices and monetary
policy or recurrent conversation among
central banks but as for the current
conjuncture I'd assert that detecting
bubbles may be hard but an accelerant to
their formation is in place right now
first okay sometimes bubbles are easier
to spot than off others
I will admit like chairman Greenspan
that in the left panel the relative
price of Bitcoin per US dollar doesn't
seem moored you can't have such a
stratospheric rise linked to plausible
outcomes but others are really hard to
spot
on the right panel is the range of house
price appreciation across 20 cities in
the United States and when it's on the
order of 50 percent one might be tempted
to say that's published when it can
swing in the range of almost a hundred
percent one may question the wisdom of
markets but these double-digit changes
also seem to be about demand pushing
against more or less inelastic supply ie
the high gains are in places where it's
hard to build and property's limited is
that a bubble or not that's a judgment
call there is I think one more much more
evident current miss allocation and
that's the lowness of policy rates
across advanced economies the Left panel
gives the range of experience across the
OECD with the euro area still having a
negative policy rate and the u.s.
inching forward but still well below its
it's it's experience but even more
striking is the right panel which looks
at the the universe of advanced economy
sovereign debt yields as of Friday and
as a Friday there was about more than
seven trillion dollars of sovereign debt
at a yield that was negative there is
more debt trading below minus 50 basis
points than there is above 4 percentage
points this isn't just about the policy
rate and sovereign securities because
that pricing equation applies to all
long-lived assets and so the effects of
low rates are everywhere and here I just
want to remind you that the asset
pricing formula that chairman Greenspan
talked about actually defines a
rectangular hyperbola as in the right ie
when discount rates are very low prices
are very high when discount rates are
very
prices are very low that's why every
Wall Street Journal article
concludes that that helpful sentence
when price bumps prices of bonds go up
interest rates go down but what the
other feature of this hyperbola when the
discount rate is very low we are pushed
against the left axis and it isn't just
that the price of long-lived securities
are high they're very nonlinear even
small changes in the discount rate so
what that says is when the riskless rate
is low when volatility is suppressed the
prices of long-lived assets are inflated
and small changes in any element of the
discount rate the riskless rate risk
premium or expected capital gains
produce large changes in rates so
central bank action matters and if I
were to sum up I just remind everyone
pricing long-lived assets is complicated
and it's difficult to be confident and
we need compelling evidence before just
before saying they are under or
overvalued but it does seem to me that
monetary policy remains an accelerant to
over valuations bubble formation and
volatility and in the pursuit of the
dual mandate the Fed should take account
of asset prices and and especially so in
weighing the risks surrounding the
achievement of these goals if that
subliminal message was was too obtuse
unsustainable unsustainable take account
of asset prices and weigh the risks
surrounding thank you thank you nice
turn back to balance which is negative
[Laughter]
thank you I actually was live-tweeting a
bit of Vince and
now I'm gonna set my timer so it's a
pleasure be back Desmond was kind enough
to bite me back he and Alex and I
participated in a session on breads and
in this room six months ago that went
very well
even if brexit hasn't and similarly I
expect this session to continue to go
very well even if the bubbles do not um
I guess I am the one notch more relative
optimist because I do think there are
ways of coping with the situation we now
see and I do worry less about the
immediate situation in terms of damage
to the economy that some of my
colleagues here this is not because I
have a cosmically different view than
bill or chairman Greenspan or anybody
else I make no pretense of knowledge
about the rationality of people one of
the things I live-tweeted was I like
Vince's comment the American dream is to
get rich quick
he clearly the Bitcoin chart should rash
should rattle anybody's faith in in the
ability of markets to always get it
right so it's not about that what I do
want to do pick you up on some of the
big questions that Alec set for us is to
talk a little bit about monetary policy
versus sorry regulation in dealing with
asset prices and bubbles and I have a
slightly different view I know the bill
and I think if you buy my view you'll be
a little bit more optimistic and I'm
hoping you'll buy it for its logic but
at least buy it for its optimism the
basic point is we do know a little more
not from so much to the rationality of
individuals but from the impact of
various asset price bubbles and their
collapses that has been summarized I
mean again people on this panel
contributed to this literature so I'm
not lecturing them but it hasn't really
been set out and so a few things which
have to be mentioned first in the spirit
of vince's last slide there is the issue
when do you go after asset price bubbles
if you are a central bank and it's not
just a matter of the trolley problem or
your willingness to take blame or even
your ability to identify bones it is the
fact that we going up until and through
the last crisis you would have depending
on the country anywhere from three to
eight very large asset price
appreciations for every crash and by
crash I don't mean just correction I
mean a crash being something that the
massive prices come down and they have a
material effect on economic growth and
so as you're calculating how to deal
with this one of your calculations has
to be not just how bad is it going to be
or how out of whack is this pricing but
how many false positives you're gonna
kill off before you actually make it
worthwhile and this goes back to
something we were talking about the ER
text of Greenspan's remarks another key
text was the 98 Jackson Hole paper by
Ben Bernanke and mark Gertler that Alan
Greenspan I believe praised at the time
which argued that it wasn't worth it for
central banks to pop bubbles and that
argument loses some force when you see
just how bad is the aftermath of a
really bad bubble but it doesn't get
totally overturned so the first point is
not every time you see an asset price
boom does it have the same effect the
second point is that this extends even
more so to debt
Bill and his former colleagues work at
the BIS
Vince and his co-author Carmen Reinhart
and others have done all I work on this
but the fact remains there isn't a
simple one-to-one mapping between the
level of debt you have in a country at
any given time and the amount of pain
you're gonna have later and I get I know
you're not claiming that but I just want
just want to point this out and in fact
quality of debt matters and there are a
lot of nuances to it but I think the two
big lessons we would take or at least I
would take from the literature is first
real estate debt and real estate over
valuation is much more damaging and
worse than almost any other form of debt
and their variety of reasons for this
but it's just empirically obvious so
even before this most recent crisis ugy
Rick Michigan and other distinguished
economists have documented that the
worst downturns in US economic history
were generally those involving real
estate crashes and if they didn't have
real estate crashes the effects were not
that big and if you look
cross-sectionally what happened in
Europe in those last crisis those that
had the real estate problems Ireland
Greece Spain did much worse than the
other countries that like Italy that had
debt but didn't have the real estate
problems the second thing we know which
is this is one place where I will
express a little surprise at my
colleagues we haven't heard the word
leverage once I think or if we did I
missed it
leverage matters so it's not just asset
prices it matters how much the system is
levered up and this is something that
thankfully in part due to Vince and many
of his former colleagues at the Fed and
Nellie Lang is now down the street at
Brookings and others we actually do have
data and more importantly we actually
pay attention to it now the the
unfortunately getting cut back Office of
Financial Research at the US Treasury
have been doing good work on this but
anyway central bankers are at a minimum
paying much more attention to leverage
and this is worthwhile because and this
is the same argument why for example we
haven't designated asset managers the
same kind of systemically risky
institutions as banks because they're
not levered you sell a passage there's a
counterparty and immediately liquid so
there's a fundamental logic there and
then the third point I would make third
broad point I would make in my remaining
I think four minutes
anyway um of course my phone shut off um
337 four minutes is right thank you is
that you have to think very hard and
convinced it's written about this
elsewhere but didn't come up in his
remarks you have to think very hard
about what tool you're gonna use if you
decide you're gonna pop a bubble if you
decide that you've identified one if you
decided it's worth it if you decide
there's enough leverage in the system if
you decide it's really you go down the
list say okay it's worth it even though
we admit there's gonna be cause you
gotta decide which tool and an argument
that's been running for a long time
which goes back to the Bernanke Gertler
paper of 20 years ago in which I've been
out there on it quite a bit is the idea
that there are tools other than the main
interest instrument interest rate of
monetary policy you want to use and to
me the way to think about it is I'll
take a famous quote that I think is
hundred percent wrong so the very
distinguished Jeremy Stein who's back at
Harvard but served on the board of
governors the Federal Reserve gave a
quote one saying the great thing about
monetary policies it gets in all the
cracks that is precisely wrong the whole
point of the financial crisis was that
markets fragment you can't price things
there are individual institutional
regulatory and other incentives in each
market there is no easy substitute
ability if monetary policy got in all
the cracks we would not have had the
same problem and well it certainly we
would have recovered much faster and so
the emphasis has been on this ugly name
but we haven't come up with anything
better of so-called macro-prudential
policy and it's not great and we're
still learning but there is evidence
including among my former colleagues at
the Bank of England recently that you
can do some real leaning against the
wind through macro-prudential policy
then as opposed to just tightening rates
so why does this make me more optimistic
because then if we look at the current
situation I think central bankers
including the ones we now are having
come to leadership at the Fed do
recognize that they have to be ready to
take asset prices into account as
said they are focusing not just on asset
prices per se nobody's gonna tighten
interest rates just because of it
they're focusing on the right issues or
at least approximately a closer
approximation of the right issues of
distinctions than they used to and then
you look around right now and as was
happened to be pointed out in Vince's to
some two piece chart if you look at the
real estate prices in the US the real
estate situation is not as bad by any
means as it was 10 15 years ago in terms
of over valuation I'm not saying go buy
in Nevada right now I'm just generally
and the leverage is much less and this
is the place where I differ a bit
interpretation with Bill I think his
description about the regulator's got it
maybe ahead of themselves trying to
prevent the next crisis rather than
cleaning up the previous crisis so
there's a lot of merit to that but one
of the good things they did is they
really clamped down at leverage and even
to the degree they didn't formally clamp
down we know historically after
financial crisis and we're seeing it now
because people are trying to cover their
butts and especially with supervisors
and with owners of banks they put out
less leverage after a financial crisis
so I am much less worried right now but
I do want to go back to something I
think bill referenced and you were
referring I think to Scott talking about
this and I've written about this and
others have that we have constrained the
Federal Reserve its emergency powers are
different than they were that came in
part of dodd-frank the macro prudential
framework in the US it goes through this
interagency committee called the
financial stability Oversight Committee
or overs accounts I can't remember F
sock and as all of you who've worked and
watching know interagency committee is
another word for death you have no
direction you have no power you have no
ability to act quickly and so to me the
short-term policy issue to get ahead of
the curve for the next problem is to try
to learn from others macro-prudential
policy and improve the process of the US
but I am admittedly less worried than I
think some of my colleagues here the
going to face that problem imminently
thanks Adam and thanks very much for
bringing up the central role of real
estate in in financial crises and it
goes with leverage because real estate
sometimes tends to attract more leverage
than have been many other things at
least and they do go together
our final speaker is Desmond Lachlan yep
thank you Alex
I not sure that I was happy with the
description of always being optimistic
pessimistic I rather see myself as a
purveyor of realism you know just give a
reality check periodically uh what I
want to say is one thing I meant to say
which gonna might answer where I come
out on the issue is is this time
different you know my answer is yes this
time is different it's a lot worse than
2008 sunny now the points that I want to
make you know or basically two points
you know maybe echoing bill to an extent
but giving some slides that will
substantiate the point the first point I
want to make is that we've got all the
ingredients for the 2008 style crisis
the second point relates to the timing
to the triggers there can be many
triggers for this but I'm bold to say
that the triggers are coming into place
rather quickly in the sense that we're
going to be getting a tightening of
monetary policy and as soon as the
interest rates go up that is when the
liquidity comes down and that's when all
of these asset price bubbles burst so
that's what I want to develop in the
remaining time of God though I just want
to say make quite clearly the statement
that at the heart of this I'm not
assigning blame for the central banks
around the world and we've just gone
through the
extraordinary period of central bank
history where the Bank of Japan the
European Central Bank and the Federal
Reserve have managed to expand their
balance sheets of the past seven or
eight years by something like ten
trillion dollars taking out of the
market all of the risk free assets
pushing everybody into risk and that is
really the underlying reason why we in
the situation we're in today so let me
go through the ingredients of the bubble
of the the ingredients of why I think
we've got a crisis coming on a rather
big scale the first is Bill has referred
to the fact that debt levels today are
very much higher than they were on the
eve of 2008 the second point I'd make is
that bubbles or credit mispricing or
asset mispricing if you don't want to
use a pejorative term like bubbles
but the mispricing of assets is very
much more pervasive than it was on the
eve of 2008 then the bubbles were
largely the United States housing market
the United States credit market without
developed right now is that these
bubbles really transcend all markets
this is really a global phenomenon and
it's not really surprising because we've
had so much liquidity in central banks
around the globe and the third reason
for my pessimism this time around is
that the room for policy maneuver is
less than before
that monetary policy is constrained by
the zero bound Pete there be resistance
to quantum easing and the Trump
administration in their wisdom have
decided to use up the room for fiscal
policy response during the good times
rather than to save it for the bad times
so let me go on to develop each of those
points on the the debts take that first
ingredient that the world is really
drowning in debt
and out you know just look at this chart
you know come from place like the
International Monetary Fund when you see
the debt levels increasing at a very
much faster rate than the black line
there which is the rate of nominal GDP
growth so what it means is debt to GDP
ratios now as bill has mentioned or
something like 30 40 percent of GDP
higher than they were on the eve of the
crisis what bothers me is that the debt
has increased in a lot of economies
there are very important and that can
have a very big bearing on the economy
so you know for instance like if you
look at this chart this courtesy of the
IMF we see that China has had a credit
bubble the likes of which we haven't
seen before the rapidity with which
Chinese credit is growing this is
problematic this means that at some
point the second largest economy of the
world is bound to go on to a very much
slower path pretty much like Japan did
which would be problematic
then there's the minor point of Italy a
country not known for its ability to
grow its way out of growth and not known
for its political stability not known
for its strength of its banking system
but known for having debt to GDP
continually rise so we have a very much
higher rate in Italy and I just
mentioned in parenthesis that the
Italian bond market just happens to be
the third largest bond market in the
world after in the United States in
Japan so we've got a situation there
that is bothersome though mentioned the
issue of emerging market corporate debt
emerging market corporate debts
they've been issuing debt at the rate of
around a trillion dollars a year you're
just a small number the debt has kind of
gone up from something like ten trillion
to twenty five trillion ran about three
trillion dollars of that is
dollar-denominated debt you know which
is problematic considering that we've
got a Mexican election coming up in June
looks like it's gonna go the wrong way
populist on the left going to come in I
don't know what that means for the
United States Mexican relations or what
it means for investor confidence but
it's not too good that they've got a lot
of corporate debt and of course there's
Brazil which is moving in a totally
dysfunctional way you know politics that
is problematic let me go into the
question of the bubbles that the bubbles
are so much more pervasive that than
before so the first charter put up is
just these are hundred year charts that
of the equity valuations in the United
States we've only been here three times
before you know this looks a little bit
before the 29th crash that we shouldn't
give one comfort so you've got bubbles
in the equity markets but that's the
least of my worries my worries is more
in the bubbles or the mispricing that
we've got in the credit markets we've
spoken about government bond yields
being at the lowest level historically
that Vince mentioned you've got stall
around about ten trillion dollars of
government bonds selling at negative
interest rates but the real problem for
me
is the risk products that spread levels
have gone to so lower levels this is
really an accident waiting to happen
so whether you look at the United States
high-yield market you know we're at lows
you look at the merging market corporate
despite all of the debt that the
interest rates are at ridiculously low
levels collateralized loan obligations
and we thought that they had learned
something in 2008 experience that's back
in fashion housing price bubbles let's
just look at Australia let's look at
Canada let's look at China and let's
look at the United Kingdom those are in
bubble territories so the point I'm
trying to make is that we've got bubbles
it's not just the stock market bubble
its credit market bubbles all over the
globe and that means that you're going
to get financial distress when this
thing unwinds I can't resist just
pointing out at a minor level you know
just if you doubting my discomfort about
how irrational lending has become you
might just want to reflect on the fact
that Italy the country with all of these
problems and Portugal they borrow at a
lower rate than the United States
government you know kind of like what
people in the bond markets are thinking
beats me that you've got countries like
countries like Mongolia Iraq Tajikistan
most bond mark bond traders I'm sure
can't place most of these countries on
the map yet they lend them money they
oversubscribed their their deals
Argentina just placed a hundred year
bond minor detail use Argentina has
defaulted five times in the last hundred
years that didn't stop them from placing
a hundred on so there's a little bit of
mispricing
all over in the markets that should
worry let me go on to the triggers that
the triggers could be anything you know
it could be I'm not saying that it's
going to be the interest rate but but
the interest rate story makes me think
that that is these bubbles are not long
for bursting you know I would say I
realize that economists should make
predictions but shouldn't give time
frames but I in this case I'd say that
I'd be bold enough to say that this is
within a year or twos business you know
because the monetary cycle has totally
changed and the reason I say that it
with the pedigree of confidence is
what's going on in the United States
that the United States economy is in
risk of overheating the Federal Reserve
has done very little to do it its way
behind the curve so the reason I say
that is that monetary conditions have
never been so easy and what monetary
condition this is a chart it doesn't
have a good heading but it's a chart
from many people put these financial
conditions together what
- look at how much impulse the economy
is getting from the combination of
interest rates a cheap dollar big
increases in equity prices so what we've
seen is we've seen massive increases in
equity prices the last year the Fed does
nothing to offset that
so monetary policy is very stimulative
at a time that full employment is very
close that we're already seeing
inflationary pressures and if that's not
enough of an argument the administration
manages to do an unfunded tax cut and a
spending increase that's going to add
another point of GDP of stimulus in each
of the next couple of years so as you
get this overheating we're going to get
interest rates rising I would just say
in conclusion that those who take
comfort from the fact that you might
have a compliant Fed not raising
interest rates and that's going to keep
this party going or forgetting about
something called the bond vigilantes
when they see that inflation is getting
out of control
they'll be dumping the bonds they'll be
driving up the interest rates the
interest rates will increase in a in a
less orderly way than if the Fed were in
front of the curve and I think that
that's the more likely scenario but my
expectation is that we're not far from
seeing this whole house of cards unravel
and I think that the question that bill
raised is the right question is that
it's not too early for us to be thinking
how do we get out of this ever repeating
cycle of bubbles with fiat money
you know we've go from 2008 we're now
going to go to another one in my view
the next year or two how do we get out
how do we respond to this in a way that
doesn't set us up for the next cycle in
10 years time thank you Alex
thanks Desmond and thanks to all the
panel for very stimulating and
provocative comments I'd like to give
the panelists each a couple of minutes
three minutes absolutely
maxximum just to make any comments you
want and what somebody else said or draw
further points of your own so bill you
want to start how can I say I agree with
I agree with them all particularly of
course with with Desmond but the the
points and and and and and and Vince but
I I guess the the point that I want to
make about that Adam made about the
regulatory side I think actually is a
very important point and there's a
there's a long literature on this stuff
now there's a piece by I hate jour de
Schuler ik and somebody else Hong Kong
Monetary Institute with very very long
database pointing out that if you're
looking if you're looking for the
villain it's it's property it's in its
housing and this goes back not say it's
always I'm always involved but but it is
involved and so that gives you some sort
of belief that perhaps you might be able
to use regulatory policies in a
thoughtful way to try to deal with the
housing thing as such or the commercial
property thing is such so much of the
emphasis today has been on monetary
policy but it's a much broader set of
issues and a much broader set of
instruments having said that I just want
to make one last point and and about the
use of macro prudential it was actually
the BIS I mean before I even arrived
that macro prudential was invented okay
by Alexander Lam falou see the
subsequent father of the euro but the
basic idea which is an idea I think that
the BIA still holds to is that when you
have a situation where you observe sort
of broad bubble like characteristics not
just in one area but going back to two
Desmond's point where you've got broader
implications of excessive credit
expansion but housing is a big chunk of
it that the recommended policy response
would be some combination of tighter
money because I think it
it does help deal with some of this over
leveraging and whatever some combination
of that plus macro-prudential so that
the two would be moving essentially in
the same direction but at the moment
what we've got is something it's totally
different and I don't think has been
adequately researched that the whole
point is that we want to use
macro-prudential today or at least many
people say that in order to allow
monetary policy to continue to be lower
for longer so this is a situation in
which these two big instruments are
working at cross-purposes as opposed to
supporting each other in a complementary
way and that's that's a big that's a big
difference
so I think when we talk about macro
prudential is certainly some use for it
but it's got to be done in a way that
doesn't overtly conflict with the
conduct of monetary policy Thank You
Vince just three points and and and the
first is I reside in the uncomfortable
middle we really should have a pretty
high hurdle assets or grossly missed and
when when we are in that other other
range it is appropriate to that it
influences the setting of monetary
policy but it is not the day-to-day
business of central bankers to be
opining on as asset values I think that
my wife Carmen I did a paper for Jackson
Hole a few years back and looked at the
15 worst financial crises of the second
half of the 20th century
ten years after a severe financial
crisis the level of GDP per capita is
fifteen percent below what the trend of
the ten years prior to the crisis would
have predicted part of it is about human
nature we really coil from risk-taking
and it takes a while to convince people
to come back part of it is the
regulatory pendulum swings we we over
tighten
to make sure that this whatever this is
even if we haven't defined what this is
never happens again and I think that
regulatory over over-tightening is is is
material right now and then the the
third point is if you tell me that
sovereign debt loads are very high that
central bankers are worried about debt
loads across households and firms and
they just so happen to be very luck
reluctant to raise interest rates I
would say that that's not an accident
that that in fact is a mechanism to
erode the real value of that debt over
time in which case the the next of event
may not be about the financial crisis it
may be about the inflation up turth
thanks I guess the the only thing I
would add is that the inflation upturn
and the bond vigilantes and and all that
I would just be a little cautious again
I know you're not saying otherwise I
just I just want to I want you should I
would are just people to be a little
caution with that for three reasons
first is today's GP I plant print does
not make an inflation spiral okay we
ignored four to six months of declining
CPI numbers in the second half of 2017
rightly and you may not want the Fed may
not want to overreact to a couple months
of high data in this six-month second as
what's implicit or pretty explicitly in
it some of my colleagues remarks you
know let's not just keep referring to
costs in the abstract as as as Vince
clearly put forward with the body on the
tracks in the in the Charlie problem if
we cut off a recovery when you're
pulling people back into
work that has material long-lasting
effects for possibly millions of people
so you know we should not get to pre-op
pre-emptive here I mean unless you were
very confident and the third thing just
to go back to what I said earlier is
even if the bond vigilantes kick in as
as Desmond says I would not count on
that popping the bubble
you could have a steepening of the yield
curve done by market forces that affects
US Treasury rates but that does not
necessarily and again I know you weren't
saying that but that does not
necessarily uniformly take care of
everything that's sort of the point we
came back to and why bill mentioned the
background breath thanks Desmond yeah I
guess I'd like to make two points you
know one is I can understand you know
the feds reluctance to pop bubbles you
know they don't know whether the bubbles
exist and so on and so forth what I
can't understand is how the Fed in 2017
seemed to be totally oblivious to the
fact that asset prices were increasing
at that rapid rate and the reason they
should have been paying attention is if
stock prices increased by 25% as they
did last year that means wealth in the
United States increased by something
like six trillion dollars people spend
part of that wealth that is equivalent
to several interest rate cuts the
Federal Reserve despite asset prices
going up and I'm not including house
prices other prices going up injecting
all of this wealth the dollar
depreciates by 10% the Fed stays on the
same path that it stays before so what
the feds done is put us into a situation
where not only did they allow the asset
price bubbles to continue to inflate
during the year but they've put the
economy at risk of overheating that that
gives the drive you know that's the
reason that we're great at in my view
that's the reason why the
Hana means growing as rapidly edges as
it is that's the reason why you're
beginning to see signs for inflation the
Fed is way behind the curve you put us
into a difficult situation
the second point I'd like to take issue
with is the trolley analogy you know I
think that it's very nice to say well
maybe you're gonna kill 12 people this
way maybe you're gonna kill two people
that way what do we do I don't think
that that is a fair analogy because I
think that the analogy should be there's
a very high probability that we're
creating a bubble when that bubble burst
millions of people are going to get
thrown out of work not only a millions
of people gonna get thrown out of work
but after 2008 we're going to be putting
the economy on a low growth path this is
the weakest recovery we've had for the
last umpteen years growing at 2% a year
of that bigger recession so the costs of
allowing the bubble are so high the
probability is so great that what are we
doing there for the sake of one
miserable percentage point of GDP we
prepare to risk the whole economy and
that is I think the fundamental mistakes
at the Fed this is the point I have to
fundamentally disagree with my friend
Desmond the there was a missing step
there that he asserted he said the
problem when you didn't think there's
this bubble the probability is so high
that you will have all these people out
of work that is empirically incorrect if
you take the Reinhart Rogoff data set if
you take the imf's data set of financial
crises of basa price bubbles you go
through them most of the time they do
not result in large downturns so you you
can do this argument you're doing
Desmond but you can't assert that it's a
high probability because you see a
bubble many people will be out of work
well I just say let's have this
conversation in a year or two but before
we do that let's look at what happened
in 2008 you know that this has got all
the signs of 2008 you know I think that
the Fed has been derelict in its
responsibility not to take into account
you know because if you just had a
bubble
or to that what you've got bubbles right
around the globe you've got miss pricing
of credit markets that is huge I think
that what they're doing is they're
taking comfort in the fact that they
might have a better handle on the banks
but what they forgetting is that 70% of
the credit is intermediated through the
shadow banks and they're forgetting what
happened in 1998 with the LTCM crisis
when they caught up sides this is where
the real stress is going to be it's
going to be in the side of the lightly
regulated hedge fund that kind of
community where we've also got problems
of too big to fail and the
inter-linkages are so large they'll take
the financial system with it which
you'll raise which illustrates my
precise point that a 98 LTCM blew up and
it's a lot of hedge funds lost money and
nothing happened to the real economy
I've got a short comment from Bill I
just I mean I respect what Adam said
about the sort of the average out turn
you could have a bust and it doesn't
necessarily you have big effects on the
economy it depends on which financial
asset you're looking at but I think when
you look at the developments over time
it does seem clear that the incidence of
these these bubbles that have real side
effects is getting greater and the
magnitude of the effect seems to be
getting greater as well I would just add
that it's not just it's not just the
economic saying so I hear people and
others have had this out you know if you
run the economy let's say super hot for
30 years you get more gains in GDP than
you lose when you get the inevitable
down you know big downturn the problem
is it's not just the economics it's the
it's the social and the political
aspects of it and again now there's a
literature the one piece comes to my
mind is 20 Schulich and Trish is the
name yeah three German guys that have
used this sort of database of Schulich
and Taylor you know that a long
historical database and they look at the
political aftermath and what you see
traditionally is what we see today is
that you get a polarization after one of
these big financial crises between
the Socialists on the one hand it's not
left and right it's the Socialists on
the one hand and it's the Nationalists
on the other hand and you put the two of
them together is in 1913 you get the
National Socialists and so we shouldn't
just think about this as doing a kind of
economic calculus there's a political
calculus and then we're back into
Vince's world where you have to realize
that that's even more on it's even more
uncertain than the economic side but the
costs can be significantly greater
gone.that know we could weaken okay bit
you're the only one who hasn't had
another term was the discussion of the
Jackson Hole paper one thing we we had
done but didn't put in the papers the
probability of regime change in the five
years after a severe financial crisis in
that sample is about twice a very good
and provocative point before we come to
your questions ladies and gentlemen I
just want to do reminded I want to
remind us all Vince's curve of the graph
of how small when you start from a very
low base what how small the changes in
real long-term interest rates can be to
get big changes in asset prices which i
think is central to these discussions
now we are going to get your questions
and thank you for for being here with us
and I she was waiting before because you
were trying to get in before and then
let's see where I'll come this way here
a reminder wait for the microphone tell
us your name tell us your affiliation
and proceed promptly to your question
and now it's your turn
thank you for a fascinating panel so
there is a competing tell us your name
and Association grace cool gesina
Capital Management there is a competing
view in the monetary policy circle that
technology has soft inflation and the
predominant worry we have these days is
inflation being too low not that
inflation would run too hot and it seems
like Newton Friedman's theory is kind of
dead given how much technology is
changing the world do you agree with
this theory and you know how do you
think about that
Najee and productivity in today's
economic policy setting okay you want to
take a crack at that
I think there's I mean I've painted a
fairly dismal story here largely to do
with debt to Genie ratios globally going
up well it may well be that there will
be productivity increases of such a
magnitude that it will overcome those
kinds of tendencies and will get big GDP
increases and debt - Genie will
gradually go down the only problem with
the productivity story is it's gonna
have to be a big change because the
demographics are working in the wrong
direction in terms of nominal GDP growth
and we've actually seen very little
evidence to date of the productivity
increases that a lot of people think
might be coming down the road here there
are people who far more expert than I am
of totally different views about what
the future is going to bring I tend to
be more optimistic I sort of tend to
think that we're at the verge of
technologies interacting in a way like
the iPhone you know nothing really new
in it but it's a combination that really
makes a difference but guys like Bob
Gordon say it's not it's not gonna
happen so again we go back to sort of
doing your kind of calculus and I would
be I think it would be imprudent to
count on technology helping us out
could I just had one thing though and
that is that it may well be that for
various reasons you know the change in
the character of what it is that's being
produced but that's what's actually
driving a good part of the price
decreases and as I said right at the
beginning of my comments if you get
price decreases that are a byproduct
somehow of supply-side shocks this is
not a bad thing and I didn't really
mention it in my presentation but I do
think one of the mistakes that all of
the central banks have made is that they
their analytical models don't adequately
take into account the fact that you've
got supply side positive supply-side
shocks and if the prices want to go down
they ought to be allowed to go down the
there's a big literature now on the
issue of do inflation's cumulate and
answer apparently from the work that
I've seen is that the Great Depression
in the United States was virtually the
only time you can point at sort of much
slower real growth associated with
declining prices so that incident was
unique and to use it as a basis for the
general policy that central banks follow
in the face of price declines strikes me
as totally misguided anybody else yeah
specifically on this point I think I
completely agree that there's any sort
of mechanistic monetarism related to
money supply or anything has been
conclusively debunked it was actually
debunked in the academic literature
before the last ten years but if you
don't believe it now you have two more
contentiously what I think in that this
is by no means proven but I am
increasingly of the view that rather
than inflation being everywhere a
monetary phenomena is very much a
question of a real phenomenon about
bargaining power and pricing power on
competition in labor and product markets
which relates to what you're saying
about the changes in the world and we're
getting more and more evidence that's
what determines a lot of inflation both
long term averages but also fluctuations
and so where that leads to just to say
is this is where Bill and I flip I'm the
I'm the pessimist I have grudgingly
comes to the conclusion that Bob Gordon
and other productivity pessimists are
right it may be that productivity will
jump up my colleague Olivier Blanchard
always reminds me that at a 10-year
horizon US productivity growth is
basically a random walk so it's possible
it could jump up but when you've seen
the productivity slowdown go across the
rich world simultaneously a lot of OECD
work on this and be persistent you begin
to worry and so I do think that's going
to be a constraint on everything and
that is what I'm much more worried about
than inflation we have a couple volumes
on this coming out from Peters
Institute if you're interested don't you
have a comment and then we're gonna come
to service just first in terms of
productivity yes its across industries
in the US across advanced economies even
CEM it's it's it occurs even as you
control for reefs or factory utilization
but the fact is economists really aren't
particularly good at forecasting this we
told the world that productivity growth
slowed in 1973 in about 1980 and that
was a part of the Federal Reserve's
policy mistakes for regard to inflation
is a domestic macro person the rest of
the world's bigger and we have to take
that into account and that is a force
tending to restrain the increase in
inflation and when I talk about
inflation picking up I'm talking about
inflation ticking higher in an
environment in which we probably have
not much slack left but Janet Yellen was
basically right and then the other two
things concentration has got to be
extremely important it is a battle for
margins that is going on out there and
then lastly if we are talking about
about a bigger rest of the world and
also she talked about miss measurement
of which obviously we do a lot hey let
me come to the next question right here
I'm Paul London I was here at a few
years ago or maybe 10 years ago now and
had a very interesting time here so I've
had a bug in my bonnet for the last year
about Henry Simons who I think is most
the people on the panel know was a
founder of the Chicago School and
chairman Greenspan really touched on it
when he pointed out that there were
times during the Revolutionary War the
Civil War when people tried to answer
the question when Henry Simons raise the
question why does the government and I'm
talking now about government why does
the government borrow money when it
could print it and a lot of what Henry
Simons Milton Friedman called Henry
Simons a revolutionary
and said basically that Keynes was a
reformer a mere reformer I should say
and this panel has talked almost
entirely about federal reserve and sort
of monetary policy in that in this
context and I wonder whether there's any
chance of getting beyond this almost
total dependence on the Fed to something
better all right getting beyond that on
the Fed to something better
sheíll comments Desmond yeah I think
that's the problem
that we're in the reason that we've got
back into a situation where there are a
lot of bubbles where there's too much
debt I think goes back to the way in
which we responded to the 2008-2009
crisis in that for reasons that were
stated before different governments were
not prepared to go in with the right
kind of fiscal stimulus so what turned
out is all of the burden of dealing with
getting a recovery going was put on the
central bank you know and that is really
what occurred if we want to improve on
this next time around I'm a big fan of
helicopter money in the sense that what
we're really wanting to have is instead
of having the central bank's go out and
buy all of these assets in the financial
market distort all financial privacy's
set us up for the next crisis what you
do is you have a check being delivered
to every United States citizen financed
on incredibly generous terms by the
central banks of the world you know let
them do it that way you'll get the
recovery without distorting the
financial part I think that there's a
way that we can avoid it but I've been
around too long to know that that's not
going to fly next time around we'll
repeat exactly the same mistakes we took
before and we'll be on the cycle not
only of having booms and busts but each
boom and bust is going to
be all the bigger dimension bill its I
attended a conference last week in
Zurich rush Lacan just outside of Zurich
and it was on the sovereign money
initiative and they've got a hundred
eleven thousand Swiss people who signed
a petition for a referendum and there
will be a referendum on narrow money in
Switzerland and it turns out that
there's ten or twelve groups around the
world actually who are interested in the
issues positive money in the UK is
another one the Cobden centre and going
back again to all of these ideas about
narrow money and Irving Fisher and and
and all of these guys my sense of it is
that any change in a monetary regime is
going to be extremely the effect the
effects of it are gonna be extremely
uncertain and chairman Greenspan made a
reference to William Jennings Bryant in
nineteen eighteen ninety six and there's
a famous article by Schumpeter which
called depression in 1934 and he refers
to this election campaign and of course
William Jennings Bryan was running on
the on the basis of bimetallism which of
course would have been on the face of it
much more expansionary than just the
monetary system based on gold and Shu
Pater makes the point he said well you
would have thought that everybody then
would have sort of rushed for real goods
whose prices would subsequently go up
but they didn't the whole system
collapsed and that's the kind of
observation when you start playing
around with monetary regimes not policy
you better be very careful about how you
do it and my advice to this outfit in
Zurich was there's a lot of things that
we could do better to what's the word to
mitigate the damage done by these cycles
these credit cycles and booms and busts
there's a lot of other things that we
could do better and we should try to do
them better before we get to the last
the last refuge of the scoundrel which
is let's just change the system entirely
having said that
I I do actually think that something
went wrong somewhere in the Middle Ages
and I got it and the idea that the
government gave the power to print money
to people that are none government
doesn't strike me as odd I was about to
say I completely agree with Bill
everything was wonderful until the last
line if you compare global GDP per
capita now versus the Middle Ages we've
done pretty well so something good
happened since the Middle Ages and maybe
having governance have elastic currency
was part of that we can say when when it
gets around to debating the nature of
money it shows that economic ideas have
cycles just like financial and economic
events do whereas Desmond says in
economics is like going to the dog track
if you stay in one place the dogs will
come around again I have a question back
here I'm Danny Bachman from Deloitte so
we're the economy is finally finally
sort of kind of getting to full
employment and I go to a panel in which
everyone is worried about monetary
policy being - expansion airy and I'm
wondering not everyone not everyone
thank you so I'm wondering if what that
suggests is that is that monetary policy
can't get us to full employment and if
if that's the driving force that's
creating these bubbles and maybe we need
to go back to the secularity summers
secular stagnation and think about what
it could be that prevents the economy
from reaching full employment under
normal circumstances okay thank you how
about secular stagnation in all this can
I just so summers and I were together on
at an event in Hong Kong last week and
obviously people were much more there to
hear Larry than to hear me but in his
remarks Larry said something which he
had said earlier one of our productivity
conferences which is this idea that one
possible implication of his
secur stagnation view that fits with
current events and which frankly is more
supportive of bill and Desmond's kind of
view is that we have been unable to
sustain a higher rate of growth in the
u.s. he would say for 30 years without
having financial froth come up and that
this this is a concern now again this
links back to my response to the lady's
previous comment question which is that
says that the real limits on growth when
you start running up against those may
be the overheating you see is financial
rather than inflation in this in the
classic sense and this relates again to
what what Vince was saying a minute ago
so it's it's varied so again just to
emphasize we're getting very into issues
of monetary policy and so on but the
real economy I just want to emphasize I
think you're right to raise this the
real economy slow down the slowdown in
productivity growth that's the real
stuff and again it may be deus ex
machina it'll just change and we're fine
but as Vince mentioned one of the ways
we've got into monetary trouble in the
70s was because the monetary policy and
the political world was unwilling to
adapt to a lower productivity growth
rate and going back to where Bill
started this morning demographics
obviously play a role in that and
there's only so much policy can do about
that I think is you you can tell the
story that the Federal Reserve actually
was a serial bubble blower over the last
30 years tack housing and so on I think
the issue is about levels versus rates
of growth the Federal Reserve has to
take is given the path for aggregate
supply
it's about demographics it's about
productivity it's about governmental
policies generally but not central bank
policy and right now we're at a junction
where Janet Yellen was right she
provided policy accommodation to fill in
aggregate demand to aggregate supply but
we're at the point now
we're plausibly resource uses is
complete and the Federal Reserve should
take opportunities to continue to
renormalize monetary policy if if it
does so inflation probably will take
higher but we'll also say in a couple
years that was pretty successful
isn't it I would just question a little
bit of what VIN said is I would have
thought that you know just judging by
the post 2008 experience we can safely
say that gross mistakes made by the
Federal Reserve put us on a lower growth
path you know that if we didn't have the
housing and credit market bubble and we
didn't have all of the fallout we would
have been growing at a very much faster
rate than we did before you know in my
fear is that the Fed is not only a
serial bubble blower but it was joined
by the European Central Bank the Bank of
Japan the Bank of England all the rest
and what they've done in the process
there but perhaps not i wouldn't totally
blame them because the government's
didn't leave them much option but what
they've done in the process is they
likely to have put us on a very much
lower growth path going forward I think
on that note which sums up the problems
unfortunately we are out of time
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
for being with us and let's appreciate
okay
[Applause]